مع مجله الى ان الخوف من الحرب سيخلق
ارضيه للامل الا ان المعضله تكمن في ان
الطرفين ليس لديهما مساحه كبيره لتقديم
تنازلات يعتمد طريق سنجر للخروج من هذا
المازق على خفض التصعيد بين البلدين اولا
ومن ثم بناء الثقه وعلاقه العمل تدريجيا
وصولا الى ضبط نفس بشكل مستمر
هي دعوه هندي كيسنجر للولايات المتحده
مشيرا الى ان الدول يجب ان تعمل بسياسه
خارجيه تستند الى تحالفات غير دائمه موجهه
نحو القضايا بدلا من ربط الدوله في
تحالفات كبيره متعدده الاطراف
الدبلوماسيه السابق قال ان الولايات
المتحده بحاجه ماسه الى التفكير
الاستراتيجي طويل المدى ودعم انشاء نظام
عالمي على اساس القواعد التي يمكن لاوروبا
والصين والهند الانضمام اليها لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات